bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors quelle est
l'image que joe biden souhaite donner à
sa future administration
à travers les différentes nominations
comment colombien d'évoquer deux points
premièrement technocratique
ce sont des gens retrait d'eads et des
professionnels très compétents qui sont
dans la deuxième point c'est une grande
continuité avec les équipes
obama et clinton ce ne se soucie 7 à ce
sont des choix assez logique puisque il
n'aura sans doute pas de majorité ou au
sénat donc pour les confirmations
il faut des noms de compétent mais
également des noms qui soit comment dire
centristes auraient dressé situe
l'équipe centriste ya pas y'a pas du
tout d'ouverture à gauche en particulier
pour le pour le trésor gelé thielen que
l'ancienne directrice de la banque
centrale a été choisie et non pas
elizabeth warren qui pouvaient qu'ils
pouvaient y prétendre
quelle est la figure qui ressort qui a
été marquante dans les nominations
j'ai enfin tu veux sur un petit peu tous
eu lieu elle n était déjà bien connu
ce sont des gens qui étaient qui ce qui
dans l'ensemble des numéros 2 dans
l'équipe obama au courant et de -2 et au
niveau sous secrétaire d'état et donc
qu'ils s'y prennent durant
je pense que les trucs nous intéresse
peut-être peu plus pour des états unis
c'est anthony blinken au département
d'état et michele flournoy à la défense
et du nickel a donné quelques
indications sur ce qu'il soit c'est
extrêmement classique dire c'est en ça
tout à fait en harmonie avec le passage
de deux baleines que vous avez cités
c'est leur tour les états unis comme
comme puissance comme puissance numéro
un il ya un an
tu es un petit peu interventionniste on
verra jusqu'à quel point mais par
exemple la noter que bentley dans une
interview l'année dernière avait appelé
la france et l'allemagne à se joindre au
japon et il y à l'inde pour la sécurité
de l'asie pacifique dont vous avez
compris le contre la chine bien entendu
à un aspect intéressant si c'est le
retour le retour de john kerry puisque
ça montre une volonté très nette de
revenir
comment dire dans l'accord de paris sur
le sur le climat dernier point aussi
c'est que blinken appelez comment dire à
papa programme québec ce qui va pas
parler français parce que nationale a
été un des principaux négociateurs de
l'accord avec les rangs donc il a aussi
certainement une ouverture donc ce qu'on
peut retenir c'est que il ya un côté
fermeté pas de cadeau à la chine
mais comment dire la collaboration sur
le climat fournira un sujet de
conversation ils n'ont pas dit grand
chose de la russie je ne pense pas que
il sera exactement pour ppda qui soit
pro russe mais l'iran fournira aussi
sans doute là aussi à ce sujet de
conversation oui au sujet de dans tony
blinken
on parle beaucoup de lui en france parce
que il est un francophile en tout cas
c'est comme ça qu'il est considérée est
ce que sa nomination au poste de
secrétaire d'état est une bonne nouvelle
pour les relations franco américaines en
tout cas c'est quelqu'un de la famille
de samuel bizarre c'est quelqu'un qui
connaît bien la france
il ya certainement beaucoup de contacts
pour l'instant je ne peux pas vous en
dire plus alors vous parlais tout à
l'heure de continuité
avec le mandat de barack obama au point
même que l'on parle d'ailleurs d'un
troisième mandat de laxey président
américain est ce que c'est c'est
réellement ce qu'est ce qui attend
aujourd'hui les états unis alors biden a
pris soin de préciser qu'il ne serait
pas justement un troisième mandat obama
qui l'aurait ce qui l'aurait c'est ses
propres comment dire c'est sa propre
volonté d'un entendu et obama lui-même a
dit mais bien entendu
hayden peut plus choisir pointe n'a pas
besoin de moi etc
mais la continuité n'est pas étonnante
puisque ça arrive aussi pour les
républicains vous avez des boules de
gens qui qui qui vont et viennent entre
le entre le laos il a fallu des postes
gouvernementaux et puis le conseil quand
c'est le parti d'en face qui est à qui
est en place
moi je dirais qu'il ya un petit côté mon
obama assenede et aussi un peu de
clinton avec iliad et des tonalités très
nettement
comment dire libre échangiste qui ait
changé vu qu'ils changent évidemment par
rapport à par rapport à à trump et on
pourrait s'attendre vraiment la vie est
ce que les états unis cherchent à
revenir d'une manière ou d'une autre
dans le partenariat transpacifique
qu'ils avaient refusé refusé chez trump
c'est quand même extrêmement classique
pour une illustration démocrate c'est de
la bonne administration démocrate
centriste comme on les connaît
l'impression que ça donne pour l'instant
merci beaucoup à vous à laurence hézard
et je rappelle que vous êtes un
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'université d'arras